[Musique]
je suis avec des clowns
pas mal c'est sorti en Charlie
OK et on file sur la côte en voiture
électrique en fusiblement non bah oui je
suis tes conseils c'est vrai char à
voile voiture électrique on est sur du
voyage responsable j'ai l'impression de
moi n'empêche qu'on va profiter du
voyage pour éclaircir certains points
sur la voiture électrique en 2035 ça te
dit quelque chose pas grand chose je
crois et bien en 2035 on va arrêter de
vendre des voitures thermiques et à
cette date il y aura environ 15 millions
de véhicules électriques en France alors
autant prendre de l'avance
nous on est un peu en retard
[Rires]
vraiment silencieux silencieux et en
plus je sais pas si tu ressembles et il
y a pas de vibration et alors l'autre
gros avantage c'est une voiture
électrique elle n'est pas de gaz
d'échappement du coup quand il y a des
pics de pollution comme ça se passe
souvent dans les gros agglomérations ce
type de véhicule rouler par contre il y
a un sujet par rapport aux voitures
électriques ça vient souvent c'est
l'autonomie parce que c'est entre
l'autonomie annoncée l'autonomie réelle
l'autonomie en ville par exemple et sur
l'autoroute on s'y perd un peu quoi en
fait une voiture comme celle-ci elle a
une autonomie de 230 km
www.e une citadine électrique c'est quoi
WW alti mix on dirait tennis poker
worldwide alors ça j'y peux rien c'est
pas moi qui l'ai inventé en fait c'est
un acronyme anglais alors je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails parce que tu
veux entendre ton accent anglais et je
veux pas te faire peur non en fait c'est
une énorme internationale qui a été mise
au point pour pouvoir comparer justement
toutes les voitures électriques parce
que évidemment elles ont pas toutes les
mêmes batteries et donc pas toute la
même autonomie par contre le côté mixte
tu me l'as pas trop expliqué dans Double
tennis poker
on dit mix parce que quand on teste les
véhicules et bien on les teste à la fois
en ville et on les teste aussi en cycle
extra-urbain c'est-à-dire sur des des
voies rapides ou des autoroutes OK et ça
ça change beaucoup pour l'autonomie ah
oui ça change énormément parce que tu
vois je disais que cette voiture avait
une autonomie de 230 km
en ville ça monte à
300 310 ah ouais donc ça n'a rien à voir
et oui et tout ça parce que je sais pas
si c'est marqué mais quand on est en
ville et bien on passe beaucoup tout le
temps à freiner à ralentir et ce qui est
intéressant avec ce véhicule c'est que à
chaque tu freines ou que tu ralentis et
bien on va récupérer l'énergie cinétique
de la voiture pour recharger la batterie
ouais tandis que sur l'autoroute comme
tu es à vitesse constante au final tu
peux pas récupérer
de à
50%. alors pour autant il faut pas en
tirer de conclusion hâtive parce que il
faut savoir qu'en moyenne en France une
voiture parcourt 35 km par jour tu vois
c'est des petits trajets pour conduire
les enfants à l'école aller faire les
courses aller au travail quand tu es en
ville et que tu as 300 km d'autonomie
c'est large même plus d'une semaine de
trajet d'accord sachant que tu peux
recharger chez toi les soirs
[Rires]
[Musique]
Virginie là regarde tu peux le gars je
pense
salut Virginie ça va
c'est Christophe Galtier
je suis avec des clowns ça va bien se
passer allez c'est parti
son permis encore je suis pas sûr à 100%
mais moi non plus on y va en électrique
c'est cool c'est vrai qu'on envoie de
plus en plus en ville il y a de plus en
plus de place avec des bornes mais là on
va sur la côte et je comprends un petit
peu les réticences des personnes qui se
disent mais est-ce qu'on va trouver des
bornes de recharge bon alors pour être
tout à fait franc avec vous l'autoroute
c'est pas forcément le terrain de jeu de
la voiture électrique surtout comme
celle-ci il y a une citadine électrique
pour autant on peut quand même s'y
aventurer il faut seulement anticiper
prévoir son trajet et ça c'est le rôle
du copilote c'est moi le copilote non
c'est ton téléphone yes ok ravi d'être
venu c'est quoi le lien entre le
téléphone et le copieur
de trajet ok qui vont
vous éviter des petits désagréments ok
attends je fais une petite recherche
alors génération Y tu connais
jeunesse ok j'ai trouvé de charge map
par exemple ça te parle ça me parle ok
très bien alors itinéraire on va
honfleur ville la plus romantique de
France messieurs dames est-ce que tu
nous amène là-bas pour ça d'ailleurs non
non
95% de batterie on va mettre 30 % de
marge à peu près ça te va le modèle
d'assaspring on est pas mal vitesse max
tu as l'air assez tranquille Jamy
on en a pour ça va à 2h30 non avec un
petit arrêt qui sera dans 38 minutes
environ parfait pour un café tu mets de
la musique pour qu'on puisse sembler un
peu qu'est-ce que je vous mets c'est
quoi tes tes goûts du moment un peu
d'électro
entre électrique le lien est là il est
très très fort il est pas là pour être
ici Jamy
[Musique]
bien conduire respect ça fait du bien de
se dégourdir un peu les gens en bas bon
là c'est bien il y a 5 bornes de
voitures mais si tout le monde se met à
l'électrique il y en aura jamais assez
vous avez pas vu l'image aux États-Unis
pour faire giving il y avait des files
d'attente jusqu'à l'autoroute et on en a
quand même pas encore là c'est vrai
qu'on a pris un peu de retard mais
j'aime bien les chiffres vas-y fin
octobre 2022 il y avait un peu plus de
75000 bornes publics installés sur le
territoire c'est moi que ce qui était
prévu de base non moins parce qu'il
était prévu 100 000 ok alors ça
progresse et plus en plus vite et
l'objectif c'est 7 millions de bornes en
2030 alors 7 millions de bornes
publiques et privées parce qu'il faut
jamais oublier que en général on
recherche sa voiture soit à la maison
soit au bureau j'ai branché datacar
on a combien de temps là
30 minutes on va aussi pouvoir prendre
du viennoise chocolatine ou pain au
chocolat pain au chocolat
ok on commence bien
ouf mais quand est-ce qu'on sait que la
batterie est suffisamment chargée la
voiture est connectée à mon téléphone et
il suffit de consulter l'écran et je
vois là par exemple
non elle est chargée à 100%
la route alors par contre si on était
bien au chaud et là on va rentrer dans
une voiture bien froide c'est pas un
problème non plus parce que je peux
commander à distance le chauffage de la
voiture c'est ce que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs donc on va rentrer dans la
voiture ça va
et en plus ce qui est super intéressant
c'est que ça ne tombe pas sur la
batterie étant donné que la voiture est
branchée sur le secteur c'est la même
chose du coup par exemple sur la clim en
été exactement ok donc l'intérêt c'est
de refroidir la voiture quand elle est
en charge comme ça au moins tu es bien
on la met à 19 20 degrés on monte dans
la voiture et là il y a juste à
maintenir la température ok trop cool ok
on y va du coup
alors du coup c'est combien le plan Jamy
et bien là ça m'a coûté 10 euros 10
euros pour 100 km c'est quand même assez
cher non je pensais que c'était plus
accessible électrique ça c'est parce
qu'on est sur une borne rapide ok que le
kilowatt-heure est à 69 centimes d'euros
faut se rappeler que en général on
recherche la voiture électrique à la
maison ou au bureau la maison ça revient
à combien du coup en ce moment c'est
très centime le kilowatt-heure donc 2
euros pour 100 km ouais là c'est
beaucoup plus accessible
OK
[Musique]
alors Virginie première impression ça
donne quoi
elle est très souple et quand tu appuie
là c'est assez réactif ça avance bien
en fait ça c'est une histoire de couple
moteur que l'énergie du moteur est
directement disponible pour les roues
pour faire avancer la voiture la
différence d'une voiture thermique où là
et bien ça doit passer par une bielle un
vilebrequin une boîte de vitesse des
courroies etc etc il y a beaucoup de
déperdition d'énergie après ce vraiment
bien aussi c'est que ça rejette pas de
CO2 et c'est avec l'urgence climatique
c'est très important ouais mais alors
moi je me suis toujours posé la question
peut-être que j'ai mis tu vas pas me
répondre là-dessus c'est que on entend
souvent qu'avec les constructions des
batteries etc c'est pas non plus si
écolo que ça bah ouais c'est vrai la
voiture électrique il a quand même fallu
la fabriquer pour la fabriquer il faut
des matières premières donc des
ressources de l'énergie et ben au final
en sortie d'usine une voiture électrique
à une dette carbone plus importante
qu'une voiture thermique elle a plus
pollué à la construction exactement mais
bon pour comparer voiture électrique et
voiture thermique et bien il faut
prendre en compte la fabrication bien
sûr mais aussi tout le cycle de vie ok
il y a des études du coup qui nous
donnent des chiffres oui il y a des
études et ils arrivent toutes à la même
conclusion c'est que à partir d'un
certain moment c'est à dire 30 40 000 km
de 3 ans un peu plus court pour les
voitures comme celle-ci les citadines
certaines la voiture électrique à moins
d'impact sur l'environnement que que la
voiture thermique et du coup est-ce
qu'il y a des études aussi sur le long
terme alors sur le long terme au bout de
150 000 km une voiture électrique aura
émis 4 fois moins de CO2 que une voiture
thermique donc c'est quand même très
intéressant et ça c'est d'autant plus
vrai que là on est dans une petite
citadine donc la batterie est beaucoup
plus petite que pour un gros SUV ou là
l'empreinte écologique est plus
importante après bon la voiture
électrique c'est pas non plus l'unique
solution c'est toute notre vision de la
mobilité qu'il faut qu'il faut changer
il y a pas que la matière électrique il
y a aussi le covoiturage la voiture
partagée le transport en commun bien sûr
le vélo ou même le char à voile par
exemple n'est-ce pas
on arrive
voilà est-ce que vous connaissez
Honfleur parce que c'est quand même la
sixième ville la plus visitée de France
la ville des amoureux vous l'avez bien
compris
il y a plein de petits quartiers qui
valent de détour comme juste là
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous voyez les
maisons c'est c'est magnifique avec le
port quartier de l'enclos tout ça le
bassin est superbe
et après le char à voile parce que là on
est pile dans les temps
génie et en plus on a même pas eu le
temps de parler de météo et de voyage
donc vous voyez allez on va aller se
garer sur le parking de la mairie il y a
des bandes de recharge et puis nous
pendant ce temps là
alors la première chose c'est que je
vais vous demander de monter dans vos
chars vérifiez que vous pouvez diriger
avec vos pieds une fois que ça c'est
fait on vous met donc au travers
perpendiculaire à l'axe du vent et c'est
parti pour aller faire le premier virage
là-bas devant
[Musique]
let's go
tu dis je suis pas là pour être ici
[Musique]